okay so I'm black in this game efore and
just to reiterate I have the layout the
way it is so that I can't see the pieces
but the viewers can see the pieces so
we'll have a Sicilian and hello to
everyone too many names to say hi to
want to play let's play knight c6 maybe
it will play something a little bit more
ambitious let's take and then I'll play
of four Knights
assuming white plays Knight c3 will have
a four knights and I'll play e6 very
aggressive approach the idea is to play
Bishop b4 and this is one of the main
openings I recommend against especially
against lower level players very simple
line to play for black while the white
players will kind of stumble into this
so yeah to answer the questions I can I
can see the board but I can't see the
pieces I can see the notation though
which is sometimes helpful so we'll play
Bishop before ninja RP thanks for the
comment
I'm really just going for link central
pressure I probably want to play each
six next maybe got the bishop pair maybe
even h6 and Bishop h4 g5 okay so we're
training and now there's some pressure
along this diagonal like both Knights
lined up
I think Bishop Bishop g5 followed by
taking on f6 is not a great plan for
whites because especially the dark
squares white doesn't have a dark spirit
bishop now you're guessing my board is
blue
does that mean I can cheat if I stream
site stream stream sniped myself yeah I
mean if I wanted to watch my stream that
would basically be cheating because I
would be seeing where the pieces are so
I have OBS covered by the chat right now
so I cannot see what OBS sees or what
everyone else sees I think I'll take
with the b-pawn and this is my second
time doing a blindfold stream like this
I thought the first time went decently I
had the pieces at lower lower opacity so
they weren't as visible but now it
should be better and the arrows should
still be faint but visible okay so Queen
d2 probably d5
d5 is just so natural in these positions
just applying pressure
I have a threat of d4 and threatening to
maybe win a pawn okay you like the
transparency that's good to see
I do plan on playing the title arena but
I don't plan to play a blindfolded
because that would be too difficult okay
if I take the C pawn is theirs Bishop e5
check which is actually kind of annoying
assuming I'm seeing things correctly so
like if I take and Bishop e5 Bishop g7
we trade on d7 and lose casting rights
so I think I'll take with the e pawn I'm
still threatening this and I think we've
simplified to a point where it gets easy
to kind of internalize a position I'm
ready to castle next I have a very
simple structure I hope this is where my
pawns are White's pawns
my pawns were on the second rank with
now the exception of the e3 pawn gold
maintain the pin play Bishop a5 I still
have ideas of d4 if before I probably
played Bishop c7 and then maybe later I
can organize some kind of attack
man I feel like I need a command that
explains the setup because everyone knew
who is joining is asking if I'm playing
find this is a feature on Lee chess
though where you can turn off the
visibility of the pieces if you want to
practice kind of your visualization and
calculation skills which is one of the
reasons why I'm doing this makes it more
of a challenge makes things more
competitive too like when I'm playing a
1400 it's still going to be a fight so I
have to stay more focused g3 g3 looks a
little bit weakening I guess he wants to
play Bishop g2 I'll Castle and at Bishop
g2 I have rook e8 and White's having
some King issues and I'm having some
bits from Sarah Nelly oh thanks for the
500 bits
yeah I'm not sure what White's gonna do
he could play King f1 King f1 or 90 -
wait 90 - is there a rope hanging are
you sure there's a ruck hanging dad the
night spin to the rook by the Queen
which means I might even have Bishop e5
as a threat like Bishop e5 just wins
material I think I could throw in Bishop
a6 Bishop a6 King could move again maybe
I should throw in Bishop a6 as I'm
imagining if I play Bishop e5
immediately White has rook e1 and then
I'm pinned if I play Bishop a6 and I is
unpinned and he can move here it's still
better for black but wait I'm getting
distracted by bits no I think I'll play
Bishop a6 right away
thanks for the bits boys Sandvik 94 hope
this can pay for eye surgery
well thanks that will at least be some
start to a fund King g1 so now Bishop e5
looks nice
my rooks are connected so I mean white
playing rook e1 will not pin the bishop
and speaking of pins pretty sure this is
a pin
now I forgot the pond was on b4 so he
maybe had b5 in the previous position
but now it's too late
this chat yeah to answer the question
from Akshay 22000 this is a new accounts
new ish account I created it a while ago
but haven't used it until yesterday or
two days ago
yeah I'm gonna make wait do I already
have a blinded command I think I do have
a blind command blind yeah so that's
just for sending challenges nighty for
so he's trying to confuse me 94 is
attacking the Queen but I have a pawn on
d5 so why not just take it and now that
rooks still attacked
I'll probably lose the e pawn but the D
file is now hot we're now wide open so I
could play I grew eighty-eight target
the Queen
okay this is nice this is better than
last game I enjoy having time to think
am i naturally this calm I don't even
have tea I forgot to get Starbucks and
then when I remember it was closed so
sad c3 c3 allows a d3 squared to be open
wait White has pawns like this it's
trying to every so often I have to
remind myself where everything is Bishop
d3 is illogical wait as c3 just hanging
c3 is hanging I have a queen on that
sixth Oh
pretty sure
feels odd that white would allow that
okay wait just resigns okay well that
was nice and the thing was visible so
now I'm looking at OBS I see the
position see I had a pretty good grip of
what was happening but I would have to
switch scenes so this is what I see if I
go to analysis board I can then see the
pieces but question if I switch back
okay so now it should be okay
yeah overall I think this is pretty
smooth I think someone pointed out I
missed Bishop takes c3 which I
completely forgot about it it's probably
the best move yeah it's much better
because forcing lines okay but it still
worked out in the end and it's bits from
coward pawn thanks coward Kong fix this
a little bit do that okay let's play
someone else I posted the tweets but the
tweet shared the wrong link to challenge
me wonder how many people saw the tweets
let's play Matt I want to challenge good
luck Matt's
okay wait so it should be working I
always have to double-check the view so
I'm white I'm playing Matt Matt's a good
player
we played over the board in in st. Louis
and we have a very long fights so I have
to think let's play E for
so this is five five hey it's a sub the
first sub of the stream playing out of
three
that's another sub but I need to focus
let's play this it was other sub tricks
27 and the goods thanks guys for subbing
I can't resist I'm gonna play a
Halloween gambit even though I'm
blindfolded it's too much fun to resist
and d4 I've had so many like good
experiences with this opening lately and
E 5 and now this does the the window
size keeps changing I'm sorry if it's
off also if I feel like he knows what
he's doing
let's play Bishop d3
yeah if someone can like type up a
description of explaining how this is
working and then I'll add it as like a
nightbot command and then I'll play you
next whoever comes up with like the the
simplest description for the people who
are just joining that would be very
convenient okay I'm gonna put the bishop
on III wait he played pawn c6 because
the reason I thought he played knight c6
so I was defending my pawn so the the
main strategy when why has this
structure is to just push more pawns and
play at 4 Knight f5 is logical I'm
wondering if I can play like g4 looks
risky also like Bishop is hanging so I
could take then Bishop takes wait so
takes takes g4
and there's Queen h4 check so let's play
Bishop f2 safe move I just hang upon I
may have just hung upon but maybe not
maybe I'm bluffing him c5 is very
logical struggling here as bishops
stolen F fades so I have like Bishop b5
check but that could walk into Bishop d7
I'm very inclined to take and then play
g4 let's do it
I didn't go for this earlier because
Queen h4 check was a problem but now my
bishops on f2 whoa what's going on I
mean I can take the bishop I lose a
night but then I win this night let's do
it
this is just such a mess this is the
type of position it's difficult
blindfold chess what's going on
where are my pawns my pawns are here
there's a pawn here and here
buy one back the piece I can take on d4
I think so I have these beautiful pawns
I'm attacking the Knights
g2o there's no pawn on g2 though so I
played g4 so he just checks but I could
play King f1
Queen g5 while this is a big mess
the bishop saw on f8 skin stolen center
I just take on d5
I feel like I could maybe win the
Knights h4 but f5 is hanging but then
his Knight would be hanging I think I'll
start with Knight takes d5
no just with Chris shout-out to chest
with Kris just posted a really
entertaining YouTube video of our game
that I played in the first blindfold
stream
I completely forgot he could Castle and
this pin is very annoying now I have a
sea pawn right pretty sure I have a seat
pond also a sevens kind of hanging but
then my knight would be hanging
and my time is dwindling let's play c4
to play c4 I mean at least I'm
controlling the center this formations
vice
ah my pot has been added nice I'm so
confused
I don't understand this I can just take
those are the free gifts maybe he was
scared of my night or he wanted to play
another force and now maybe he can make
me
I've worked g1 I could also just take on
e7 wait a minute is rook c1 check rook
see one looks like check there's nothing
on the C file and the knight blocks the
Queen from attacking on the c1 and is
this just meat
that's just meat was the bishop in Queen
yeah I was I was gifted some very nice
things there I'm happy the game ended
because the position was a little bit
hard to keep track of I can go to
analysis board oh I had three pawns Oh
cuz I took on after I took on d5 I
forgot my pawn was still there that was
a fun game Halloween gambit
switch that back
thanks so much chess with Chris let's
play chess with Chris is he challenging
me
I should do this more often got people
to write a copy
in exchange for games
the ice coming up with a good stream
title I'm gonna save this for next time
because if I change it by maybe I could
change it on stream because that was
good YouTube content yeah for the
YouTube people I hope you guys enjoyed
that game I'll call it something like